I made 20x more money by implementing
these three things into my business
number one getting paid in Bitcoin in a
bare Market this means the value of my
labor has increased over time this is
the equivalent of getting paid double
the amount of money from every single
client because since I started getting
paid in Bitcoin the value of it has 4X
number two working smart not hard this
means focusing more on creating short
form content instead of long form
content because short form content has
allowed me to go a lot more viral which
has made my brand more powerful has
blown up my audience and has allowed me
to monetize much more effectively number
three Outsourcing stop trying to do
everything yourself the best thing to do
is to invest some money into hiring
people who are experts in the field who
can do a much better job than you could
have done this allows you to focus more
on the business rather than the
nitty-gritty day-to-day things